in 2019 Tesla revealed their
much-anticipated pick up the Cyber truck
even though it looks like something out
of a science fiction film The Cyber
truck is just about ready to hit our
streets in 2023 and when it does it will
shake up the pickup truck market today I
will tell you everything you need to
know about Tesla's much-awaited cyber
truck performance first the Cyber truck
comes in three different performance
configurations the single motor
rear-wheel drive the dual motor and the
tri-motor before exploring anything else
let's look at these performance
configurations and their meaning the
first one the single motor rear wheel
drive will be able to get from 0 to 60
miles in 6.5 seconds with an estimated
250 miles on a single charge and in true
pickup style this version of the Cyber
truck will be able to tow over 7 500
pounds then there is the dual motor
hitting 0 to 60 miles in 4.5 seconds and
able to tow weights that are over 10 000
pounds finally the tri-motor which is by
far the most powerful cyber truck hit 60
miles in 2.9 seconds this cyber truck
configuration will also be able to tow
up to 14 000 pounds at about 500 miles
on a single charge these versions will
come with independent rear steering
wheels meaning that you can steer all
four wheels making it easier to travel
in all kinds of terrain but that's not
all Tesla will also offer each car owner
the option to upgrade to its new
autonomous FSD or fully self-driving
feature at an added cost say what you
will about the Cyber truck but I'm
already hooked exterior so what else
makes the Cyber truck special well after
it was first announced the Cyber truck
received mixed feelings mostly because
of how it is shaped nobody outside of
Tesla knew at the time that its angular
look and basic body panel lines were
that way because the exterior material
was too hard to shape and may break the
gigafactory stamping press if they tried
to give it a different shape and if
you're wondering why Tesla doesn't just
change the material so they can make
differently shaped cyber trucks you're
probably not the first person I'm here
to tell you that there are good reasons
for you using that material the exterior
shell is made out of a stainless steel
alloy named the ultra hard 30X cold
rolled stainless steel which was created
by Tesla initially for their SpaceX
Starship shell it is said to be
bulletproof strong resistant to
corrosion and be able to withstand
temperatures in both the hot and cold
extremes with such a strong body the
Cyber truck may be the safest pickup for
passengers in Collision accidents
recently though Elon announced that the
Starship would be using 304l stainless
steel which is just as sturdy so we can
expect cyber truck to move in that
direction in the future additionally
since its release independent studies of
the design have revealed that the truck
shape is aerodynamically significant as
well giving the Cyber truck a drag
coefficient of around 0.39 which is
impressive because most pickup trucks
feature in the 0.45 to 0.55 range so I
guess there is a method to the madness
behind this sci-fi look interior we now
take a look at the inside to appreciate
the interior of the Cyber truck which is
nothing like its in industrial exterior
its dashboard is made of compressed
paper and the Finish is made to have a
lavish marble appearance I bet you
didn't expect that huh well this aligns
with Tesla's commitment to
sustainability following in the
proverbial footsteps of the model 3
which was announced to be moving to a
completely leather-free interior
ultimately Tesla hopes to have all its
Vehicles made of sustainable interior
materials in the future but back to the
Cyber trucks interior the luxuriously
minimalist dashboard only hosts a
17-inch Center touchscreen with controls
for every truck's function the yolk
style steering wheel shares its design
pedigree with the model S plaid and will
have similar functionalities built in by
way of two control Wheels in terms of
space and number of Passengers The Cyber
truck can seat six people with a
spacious cargo hold at the back one of
the unique features of the Cyber truck
is the cargo hold cover which is also
made out of armor glass that is so
strong that it can hold the full weight
of Elon standing over it though I don't
know why anyone would want to stand over
it and as always over engineering is
what you get from Tesla anyway but I
suspect that they might use this cover
to host a solar panel in the future to
self-charge the truck now that would be
a neat use of the feature for sure
mirrors even though the Cyber truck has
all these incredible features it lacks
some more traditional features I bet you
noticed the missing side mirrors and
rear view mirrors well instead of
mirrors the Cyber truck uses cameras and
a screen to show you a live video feed
of what is outside the vehicle having no
rear view mirror in favor of a camera is
nothing new but the absence of side
mirrors is not yet allowed in the United
States simply put the version of the
Cyber truck that was displayed at the
unveiling with no side mirrors can't be
driven in the US at least until the
regulations change but that's not the
end for that design in Europe however
there is already the Audi e-tron with
cameras instead of mirrors so the
mirrorless cyber truck could be
available there while the US is still
updating vehicle regulations for now it
seems like Tesla is waiting to hear what
the final ruling will be on that before
they make their mirrorless design
official so you can expect the first
versions of the Cyber truck rolling out
of its Texas Factory to have the side
mirrors installed on them floating
abilities something that won't need
regulation change is a truck's ability
to float Elon has claimed that the Cyber
truck can drive through water and float
during flooded conditions when he called
submarines underwater electric vehicles
he used that to back up his claim that
Tesla cars can work as boats for short
periods of time because they have no air
intakes much like submarines with a
video from Shanghai making the rounds
sometime Back featuring a Tesla Model 3
traversing through flood waters musk may
be onto something with his claims the
Cyber truck looks more like a
utilitarian vehicle in this regard
especially with global warming causing
many water-related natural disasters
worldwide
supercharge another thing that makes
Tesla unique is that all of their
vehicles are electric vehicles and the
Cyber truck is not about to change that
the Cyber truck will be charged at Tesla
Supercharger stations still because of
its size and power it is being built its
own supercharging stations as the
existing ones get a refurbishment as
well the new superchargers dubbed V3
have an impressive one megawatt cabinet
that supports a rate of up to 250
kilowatts per vehicle and these aren't
even the Cyber truck superchargers for
the Cyber truck there has been mention
of V4 superchargers which are expected
to reach charging rates of up to 350
kilowatts looks like Tesla is rightfully
preparing for this powerful vehicle in
all the ways that matter battery to make
sure that the Cyber truck battery can
withstand the power that the
supercharger will provide the Cyber
truck battery will have to be upgraded
from what Tesla's been using all along
the Cybertron battery will be massive
with the entire pack at 200 to 250
kilowatt hours double the current Tesla
battery size if you remember the
performance numbers from earlier this
huge battery will make perfect sense for
a machine as big as the Cyber truck to
function that way requires equally great
power but the power of the battery
doesn't have to be reflected physically
that's why Tesla is experimenting with
prototypes that could be significantly
lighter in weight but still have great
energy storage range and an even greater
increase in power up to six times to be
exact if this is successful the weight
reduction will make the Cyber truck's
high power requirements a step closer to
reality thermal regulation now with all
those improvements to make the battery
more efficient thermal regulation could
be an enemy of such progress this might
be an obvious feature for any other
vehicle owner but for electric vehicles
it can affect a single charger's range
with losses of up to 40 percent in cold
weather Tesla intends to guard against
that by using a heat pump on the Cyber
truck making it the second vehicle after
the model y the model-wide's heat pump
works through a motorized octal valve to
transfer and distribute coolant for
thermal regulation of components and
Passengers The Cyber truck heat pump
technology will be more efficient with
its range unaffected even in cold
weather when the heat is turned up
frequently this thermal management
system is so sophisticated that it has
been likened to that of a jet engine
meaning that once again Elon Musk is
changing another industry one Innovation
at a time other features if that was all
the Innovation that the cyber trunk has
it would be enough but there are still
more more of the features that we can
expect from the Cyber truck include an
improved air suspension with Active Ride
height and active damping systems for
those who may not be familiar with these
the Active Ride height is a system that
allows for a vehicle to vary its ground
clearance this can be done to give
better ground clearance over rough
terrain which the Cyber truck can expect
to frequent like all other pickup trucks
the active damping system on the other
hand is a feature that automatically
adjusts suspension stiffness or softness
in different driving situations or
terrains this feature can make a ride
smoother by absorbing Road bumps or make
it more thrilling depending on how you
drive it is especially important to
vehicles that are meant to be driven on
all kinds of terrain because it gives
the driver more control I'm sure there
are various other features of the Cyber
truck that'll come out once the cars are
actually delivered to owners but until
then I'll keep scouring the forums to
bring you all the updates on what
promises to be a game-changing vehicle
for both Tesla and the automotive
industry as a whole well that's all I
have for you today so what do you think
of the Cyber truck do you think it is
worth all the hype let me know in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
this video hit the Subscribe button and
continue watching our videos by clicking
on one of the cards on your screen see
you in the next one